is criticism of qatar's World Cup unfair
I just spent a couple of days in Doha
covering the tournament and that is
exactly what many Arab fans told me when
I asked them about qatar's human rights
record
in the run-up to the tournament some
Western politicians like Germany's
interior Minister criticized Qatar she
said human rights must be a factor when
picking a World Cup host qatari's
foreign minister fired back he told a
German newspaper that the German
government has no problem with us when
it comes to energy Partnerships or
Investments and he added that he is
annoyed by the double standards that
feeling of being treated unfairly
resonates with qataris I spoke to indoja
is
we the media are also accused of being
unfair Western Outlets including ours
deutschevela have reported extensively
on qatar's poor human rights record with
shed light on how same-sex relations are
a crime in the country we have
highlighted issues of gender inequality
and investigated their sometimes deadly
working conditions that migrant workers
faced building stadiums critics say this
all adds up to an unwelcoming
environment for many fans of the sport
but almost every Qatari and Arab I spoke
to felt that this focus is
disproportionate and that it promotes a
stereotypical negative image of their
region is
so much you can say negativity towards
the Arab world and this time we can show
it to everyone that no this is not how
it is they told me that progress Qatar
has made to host the tournament is
completely ignored for example the
recently amended labor laws
in a region often torn by conflict fans
from across the Arab world told me they
are proud that finally a Muslim and Arab
country could pull off an event like the
World Cup so well yeah
what I experienced was a well-organized
tournament with lots of Multicultural
events parties and warm Hospitality but
the moment I address the human rights
like LGBT rights or labor rights that
Hospitality was gone here is one example
of what I mean one night I was out in
the market in sukhwakov in Doha speaking
to people and approached a local this
was his reaction when LGBT rights came
up
instead of engaging in a conversation he
immediately started making my questions
personally yes
thank you
foreign
I was very quickly surrounded by others
who supported him at some point we were
interrupted by a passerby
foreign
one of the main arguments made in favor
of Qatar hosting the World Cup was that
it would open the country up to reform
and while some progress has been made my
impression is that it is still very
difficult to have an open conversation
about human rights in the country so
what do you think is criticism of Qatar
hosting of the World Cup Justified or is
that criticism unfair